[Music]
well good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight Donald Trump jr. will be
here in just a minute but first Devon
you nez's four-page memo looks like it
won't be the last Declassified document
to shake up Congress the house Intel
committee just voted unanimously to
release a democratic counter memo one
that seeks to rebut the assertions in
the four pages that Nunez released on
Friday if you're keeping up with this we
should be able to see the new memo soon
and no matter what it says that's
probably a good thing for everybody for
the first time in generations Americans
have reason to believe that our
intelligence and law enforcement
agencies gravely misused the powers we
have given them violating the civil
liberties of Americans and taking sides
in political contests well you can't
trust a government that would do
something like that and many Americans
don't that is a disaster in a democracy
where the trust of the population is key
the transparency is the only antidote to
that so release all the documents all
relevant documents and let the rest of
us decide what they mean maybe that'll
make us trust our government again
nothing else will well Democrats
disagree with that just last week party
leaders and their lackeys in the media
were yelling at the rest of us about how
releasing the núñez memo would
constitute a deadly threat to America
they said that for days and then the
memo came out whatever you think of the
memos conclusions you got to be honest
and concede there was not a single thing
in there that you should not have been
allowed to see there were no classified
weapons programs discussed no names of
secret agents revealed Democrats it
turns out didn't want it released
because it might embarrass them so on
Friday we spoke to California
congressman Eric SWA well he's a member
of the House Intelligence Committee
right in the center of this and we asked
him the obvious question none of this
should have been secret of the memo why
did you fight to keep it hidden
well swallow it didn't answer that
question instead he accused us of
betraying our country here's part of the
exchange we had in the case of today's
memo what specifically have I espoused
that empowers threats to our country
you're peddling the narrative that the
Trump administration is putting out
which also is the
pootin narrative because they're
retweeting this with their Russian BOTS
this whitneyhl ain't you and do you
pursue WikiLeaks and Putin you should
take a step back and wonder whose
bidding are you really doing whose
bidding are you really doing so for
wanting to see the memo we are
treasonous agents of Vladimir Putin you
probably grew up reading about the
McCarthy era where demagogues in
Congress made baseless claims of foreign
collusion destroying the lives of
American citizens in the process and
probably didn't think you'd live to see
it happen again but it has about a year
ago we spoke to another Democratic
member of the House Intelligence
Committee Adam Schiff of California and
we asked him another obvious and
straightforward question what evidence
do you have that the Russian government
hacked John Podesta's email account
often alleged never proved so we pushed
Schiff got squirrely you pushed him
again here's what happened can you look
right into the camera and say I know for
a fact the government of Vladimir Putin
was behind the hacks of John Podesta
absolutely the government of Vladimir
Putin was behind the hacks of our
institution and the dump of John Podesta
is not only in the snow but also in
Europe okay you're not you know what
your dog said Tucker look and say well I
know they did jump and I think that
Ronald Reagan rolling around Reagan
you're carrying water for the Kremlin
somebody and you can't say they have
you're gonna have to move your shoulder
at 2rt
Russian television carrying water for
the Kremlin disloyalty to America
treason in a single year on this show
we've been accused of betraying our own
country by more than 20% of the
Democrats in the House Intelligence
Committee what is this about part of it
obviously is politics of the most
cynical kind the Democratic base has
been fed Russian conspiracy theories for
months now and they're primed to believe
literally anything on that subject
without within hours of appearing on
this show last week Eric swallow was out
raising money on our quote attack on the
rule of law our questions were to attack
in the rule of law by the way well
that's dishonorable and on
but at least it makes a kind of sense in
a sleazy Washington way but what if
these guys are actually starting to
believe the lies they tell in a speech
last week Adam Schiff accused Russia of
a crime so bizarre that even the most
diabolical soviet-era leaders never
would have dared attempt it watch this
they also trumpeted the Second Amendment
apparently the Russians are very big
fans of our Second Amendment they don't
particularly want a second Amendment of
their own but they're really glad that
we have one the Russians would be
thrilled if we were doing nothing but
killing each other every day and sadly
we are so if you're following along at
home how determined are the Russians to
destroy American democracy will so
determine says congressman Schiff that
they will even attempt to promote our
own Bill of Rights next thing you know
they'll be reprinting the Federalists oh
the Slovak mind dastardly this is
demented and there's no other word for
it
it grows of course from our ruling
classes unwillingness to face the
lessons of last year's election voters
rejected them they can't accept that
they blame Russia we get it but it would
cost all of this Schiff and swallow are
not college professors they're not CNN
anchors they're members of one of the
most powerful and important committees
in the Congress one charged with
overseeing our vast intelligence
apparatus they're supposed to be sober
and thoughtful and smart but they're not
instead if you dare ask an uncomfortable
question they accuse you of working for
a hostile foreign dictator strictly
speaking that's a death-penalty offense
by the way this is your opposition party
these are the people who are supposed to
be giving us an alternative to trump who
they claim is too irresponsible to rule
but they're more irresponsible and
they're angrier and they're more
reckless and most terrifying at all they
are poised to take power nine months
from right now at the midterms they may
chances are in fact they'll be running
Congress again these people the ones who
cavalierly accuse fellow Americans of
treason who mock civil liberties who
believe the US Constitution itself is
some kind of Russian ploy they'll be in
charge Adam Schiff will be chairman of
the Intel committee if there was ever
incentive for the Republicans to get
their act together
seriously and do it fast you just saw it